millions of americans are traveling far
from home over the holiday weekend the
labor day weekend others are celebrating
the new college football season all of
us are dealing with the threat from the
delta variant of covid the u.s is now
averaging more than 150 000 new cases a
day according to the cdc in august alone
we recorded more than 4 million
infections that's the highest monthly
total since january errol barnett is at
reagan national airport outside
washington errol good morning to you
hey there jericho good morning on your
celebration note you're right some of us
watch ucla beat lsu over the weekend but
the travel industry in general is
struggling to get back onto its feet
let's just look at some of the newest
data some of the fresh numbers we have
for you this morning the tsa is
reporting that more than 3.5 million
travelers pass through airports on
friday and saturday alone that is more
than twice as many than last year it is
though still fewer
holiday weekend flights than before the
pandemic let's zoom into what united and
delta are reporting each expected to fly
about 2 million people over the long
weekend that is 20 percent lower than
what they did in 2019 now this is partly
because hundreds of flights were
cancelled in the wake of hurricane ida's
devastating flooding also as we've been
reporting for weeks the delta variant
may have kept more travelers home with
cases spiking across the country now as
the weekend winds down lots of folks
this morning are wondering when is the
best time to hit the road and get home
well first of all you want to finish
watching this program but one travel
data company says the best time to
travel today on monday is uh before
and the worst time is between 1 p.m and
5 p.m this evening if you're heading
back tuesday try and avoid traveling
between 2 p.m and 9 p.m uh the advice is
it's better to wait until late evening
after 9 00 pm and one other note for
drivers those of you out in california
already know gas prices are ticking up
again folks out west paying what 4.39
per gallon that is the highest average
for a labor day holiday weekend ever
according to aaa's weekend gas watch
dana all right errol yeah i saw over
five dollars in california just a few
weeks ago thank you very much